[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à Porto Rico en transformant un cratère
naturel en un miroir concave géant les
techniciens américains sont en train de
réaliser un Radi télescope qui sera avec
celui de nany en France le plus grand du
monde suspendu à la verticale du centre
de la cuvette un radar recevra les ondes
reflété et concentré par ce miroir de
330 m de diamètre il convient de
remarquer que le montage du radar fixé
par des câbles au pic du voisinage
au-dessus du vide représente un joli
travail
acrobatique c'est peut-être ici que l'on
enregistrera demain les messages émis
par des galaxies inconnues distinctes de
millions d'années lumières de notre
mononde
[Musique]
la locomotive à vapeur qui entraîna les
trains pendant 100 ans et qui fut la
vedette d'un des tout premiers films de
cinéma n'est plus loin de la retraite le
progrès sans cesse plus exigeant lui a
donné une progéniture qui ne lui
ressemble guerre parallèlement à
laattacction électrique une autre
branche s'est développé laattraction
diesel ce furent d'abord les petits des
800 chevaux qui se chargèrent des taches
obscur des manœuvres de gare et puis là
où l'électrification n'était pas
rentable des diesels plus puissants se
sont lancés sur les grandes lignes des
chemins de fer français des diesels de
1400 chevaux apparurent puis des 2000 et
des 2600 chevaux et ce n'est pas fini
c'est ainsi que dans les ateliers est en
train de naître celui qui sera le géant
de la série un 4000
chevaux les chemins de fer y perdront
définitivement dans moins de 10 ans leur
panage de fumée mais au profit de la
puissance du confort et de la
[Musique]
vitesse dans le le domaine de
l'automobile une voiture de série prise
au hasard la voiture de monsieur tout
leemonde a battu le record du monde des
300000 km record soumis à l'approbation
de la Fédération Internationale
automobile c'est cette distance
respectable qu'à la moyenne de 106 km/h
une Ford tonus 12 m a bouclé en 117
jours sous contrôle officiel sur le
circuit de miramars six pilotes se sont
relayés toutes les 3 He au volant de
cette voiture qui avec une charge
équivalente au poids de 5 passagers a
roulé par tous les temps de jours comme
de
[Musique]
nuit cette for de tonus 12 m ne devait
être arrêté qu'au bout de 357000 km la
distance de la Terre à la Lune belle
démonstration d'endurance pour une
voiture de
[Musique]
série décembre nous promet un de ces
jours fatidiques auquel pour des raisons
mystérieuses s'attache un potentiel de
chance exceptionnelle un vendredi 13 un
jour à ne pas rater un jour qu'il
importe de mettre à profit pour faire
une démarche capitale une demande en
mariage par exemple et à une bonne
[Musique]
adresse jour unique pour tenter la
traversée de la place de la Concorde aux
heur de
pointe jour idéal pour prendre un billet
de la tranche spéciale de la Loterie
nationale avec toutes les chances de son
côté
jour ou jamais où l'on peut s'attendre à
un avis de remboursement du percepteur
et qui n'a pas ses projets pour le
vendredi
13 Paron monsieur faites de spécial le
vendredi 13 le vendredi 13 je pense déjà
aux embarras de la circulation pour
rentrer en banlieu merci et vous
monsieur que faitous le vendredi 13 je
pense à mon
weekend Mad je prendsill laterie
nationale merci et vous monsieur que
faitesv
vendred poiss du poisson et vous patron
que faites-vous de le vendredi 13 ETV le
14 je touche le
[Musique]
gagne ce n'est pas la première fois que
les jolies skilleuses empreintent la
casquette mais c'est bien la première
fois depuis 25 ans que le fuseau
rencontre un adversaire le niqueur
agrémenté bien entendu de tous les bas à
dessin ou sans dessin imaginable c'est
ainsi que Jacques Marau conçoit la
skieuse de l'hiver
6364 celle que nous allons voir bientôt
à Courchevel ou à
[Musique]
meuget toutes les fantaisies sont
permises dans cette forme nouvelle qui
si ell ront délibérément avec la
tradition ne manque ni de style ni
d'élégance devant cette offensive le
fuseau résiste mais transformé amélioré
diraiit même certains le fuseau est
devenu collant et Henry ours à la pointe
de cette formule a conçu toute sa
collection dans ce style les anorqu ont
droit à toutes les fantaisies dessins
couleurs et
[Musique]
fourrures enfin pour le soir on n'ose
pas dire le ski du soir voici la
dernière idée tunique en lamé et collant
de soie original à faire pâir le Mont
[Musique]
Blanc un nouveau visage entre à la
maison blanche le président Lindon
Johnson entouré de sa famille sa femme l
Johnson et ses deux filles Linda burn et
Lucy BES seront désormais les autres du
palais qui depuis l'année 1800 abrit le
président des États-Unis cet homme hier
presque inconnu fut le collaborateur de
Truman après avoir été guidé par
rosevelt pour ses premiers pas dans la
politique
[Applaudissements]
américaine la Convention démocrate de
1960 lui préféra Kennedy mais c'est
ensemble qu'il menèrent la campagne qui
devit les porter au
pouvoir vice-président on commença à
voir apparaître sa longue silhouette qui
portait à travers le monde la voix de la
politique
kennéiste c'est ainsi qu'on le vit à
Berlin au lendemain de l'édification du
mur de séparation bâti par le
gouvernement de POV déclaré que les
États-Unis n'abandonnerai jamais
[Musique]
Berlin c'est ainsi qu'on le vite en
Turquie accueilli par le président
toujours et partout acclamé par des fou
enthousiastes qui saluaient en lui la
puissance et l'amitié de la
[Musique]
mairie aujourd'hui Lyon Johnson est
devenu président c'est en cette qualité
qu'il a reçu après le drame de Dallas
Philippe d'Édimbourg et le de krutchov
anastas
[Musique]
mikyam c'est en cette qualité qu'il a eu
avec le général de Gaulle un entretien
particulier dont rien n'a encore été
[Musique]
révélé c'est en cette qualité enfin que
Lindon Johnson dans son premier discours
au Congrès a défini sa politique en la
plaçant sous le signe de Kennedy en ce
qui concerne les problèmes mondiaux
comme les problèmes nationaux il a
déclaré la mort de John Kennedy exige
que l'œuvre de sa vie se perpétue que
l'Amérique aille de
[Applaudissements]
l'avant
le moment est venu pour les Américains
de toutes les races de toutes les
croyances et de toutes les opinions de
se comprendre et de se respecter
[Applaudissements]
mutuellement mettons donc fin à
l'enseignement de la haine du mal et de
la violence and
[Applaudissements]
violence